good morning millennials
welcome back to the toes happy Tuesday
hope everyone's having a absolutely
stunning stunning day and speaking of
student it's my girl it's like four
different accents in one Jackie oh hey
Jackie oh how you doing I'm doing good I
just became immensely depressed when I
realized it's only Tuesday like so sorry
not okay
no because that's the thing about the
toes let me say this all the time like
we are going to let you know what day it
is and sometimes that's a negative
sometimes it's like oh my God it's
already Wednesday but then sometimes
you're like oh my God it's only Tuesday
I feel like nobody breaks down the days
of the week quite like us no and that's
why we are like the top tier of what we
do everyone else tries but nobody will
ever like break down a week harder than
Jackson Claude no we live for it I'm
surprised we don't wear undies that have
the day of the week on them that's how
much like the day of the week is part of
our personalities
oh my God gift idea
are you excited for Hanukkah
I am I did Taylor schrecker's podcast
yesterday and we were just talking about
like you know what it's like to be a
dude during Christmas time and it was
really funny
um and we were also talking about how
you know they're we as outsiders look at
Christmas is like oh my God you know
holiday cheer Joy but I think when
you're actually like celebrating
Christmas there's like you know
torturous holiday things like you've
just spent so much money for all the
gifts for all the people in your life
some people like hate spending time with
their family like it is you know I think
bet Christmas is better as an outsider
I've come to that conclusion
so true and like if you do get someone a
gift it's because you just really wanted
to and you saw something instead of
having like a list of people that you
have to buy gifts for check reversely it
does mean that all those people have to
buy gifts for you right so that's what I
was saying I'm like people think like
Hanukkah presents you really age out of
Hanukkah presents when you're 12. like
you would open up you know maybe a toy
each night you don't get like you know a
Chanel scarf every night when you're an
adult there's no real Hanukkah presence
you don't but once you become a parent
Hanukkah sort of picks back up I'm not
doing a shades of presents but I
definitely am using it as an excuse to
get some gifts for the kids
100 speaking of I sent you home from New
York with a bunch of gifts for all the
kids in Florida and I haven't heard from
Levi and Michaela's parents thus having
me believe you haven't given them my
gift yet I have not given them your gift
yet because there hasn't been a gift
exchange yet and now since you're coming
so soon and you will be here for
Hanukkah like maybe you just two birds
one stone it wrap them up
and give them like a gift wrap it up
baby
maybe wrap it up
um
I watched so much Yellowstone last night
where are you at and okay so
um they are still trying to figure out
who like ordered the attack on all the
duttons and they figured out it's this
random guy in prison and then this guy's
former prison cell was the guy Jamie is
technically related to you know it's his
biological father and like the way Jamie
is like so desperate for like any sort
of companionship he like moved in with
this guy even though he knows that this
guy killed his biological mom spent like
tons of years in prison is like not a
good guy John Dutton told him he was
like rotten to his core but he like
bought a house with him he's such a
loser but for now it seems his
loyalties are still with the duns
oh and that political girly just came
back with their son so I'm so glad we
got to tie that up the baby was born
yeah
I shall say nothing
and I figured out last night I don't
know if you know this you know that Beth
Dutton is British
the actress no I didn't know that
yeah it was shocking I also because I
found out last night that Cameron from
White Lotus Aubry Plaza's husband is
British and I was like sure because he
did a really good accent and then
someone else was like did you know Beth
Dunn is and I'm like it's weirder to
have a British person on Yellowstone
than it is to have him on White Lotus
100 they were traveling to Sicily like
there's British people everywhere yeah I
was shocked when I learned about Beth
and then I I um
I just Googled uh Beth Dutton
Yellowstone British and I just stumbled
upon this interview that her and rip did
and rip is so handsome in real life
that's so crazy that they do interviews
together and then one of them is British
it's
it's like seeing a teacher out of school
seeing a dog walk on its hind legs it's
just unnatural yeah
it's just unnatural so I'm glad you're
enjoying you'll probably be caught up by
the end of the week back where we all
are and then we can 100 conversation an
honest conversation other things on my
contemplate that I really want to watch
um Real Housewives of Miami I've been
hearing the craziest [ __ ] is going down
between Lenny and Lisa there's like a
hot mic moment
um it's on my list of things to do I
promise and the Fleischmann show as well
so that's I'm like gearing up my content
list for the holiday break you know I
think everyone should do that yeah I
have a huge content list for break and
hopefully over the two weeks that we're
not doing the toast by the time we come
back we have like so many TV Recaps to
do for you guys I went to start one of
the many shows on my content list last
night I was like shall it be Wednesday
shall it be the fleischmann's White
Lotus and instead I started a new book I
just I can't explain I was not in the
mood to like fall into a TD Rabbit Hole
where I'd be like up till 3am caring
about a show no let's talk about this
because I saw your Instagram story and
you're reading a book that's 28 hours
long now for context if you don't read
an average book like Kindle will will
tell you how long it'll probably take
you to read like a 300 400 page book
it's usually like six maybe five hours
27 hours first of all what [ __ ] book
how many pages is that
uh I think it's 700 something Pages
no or it's more because it's more I'm
having a hard time finding the book on
Goodreads because it came out in the 60s
and when it came out it was volume one
and volume two and I can't tell if
volume one has 700 pages but the book
I'm reading now the Kindle version they
put it together into one book so yes yes
volume one had 700 Pages volume two had
like 400 something so maybe it is like
1100 1200 pages
while also speaking of books we have a
brand new episode up on our patreon that
Jackie and I recorded um it's our annual
episode every year we get together and
just take a look at the year at a glance
talk about our favorite books that came
out movies TV shows uh songs albums just
like you know the toast wrapped if you
will and it was a gorgeous episode it's
available on the patreon and I think you
should go check it out I really do yeah
it was so much fun it was so nice to
like hear what you've been up to what
you were liking and take recommendations
from like your best of the best and our
interests were so varied which is so
surprising that's what I was gonna say
in in past years the episodes have been
much shorter because Jackie and I have
like the same top five for everything
maybe we rank them differently but for
the most part we have the same top five
and I feel like yeah this year I feel
like you really matured
um obviously like you had a child and
you had all this free time on maternity
leave and three times I'm sorry on your
when you were pregnant free time no
before like while you were pregnant you
had like so much like TV you were
watching until you were like doing
different things you know you were
becoming a mother you were nesting and
it was you know I've never felt further
away from you oh mclartio we're so
distant
near
far
wherever you are I'm kind of having like
Sticky Shoes moment you're having a
Phoebe Buffet
flu season moment because it is fact
that when you're sick your voice is
better it has this very erotic Very
sensual
must sticky sticky shows I believe that
the Heart Will Go On except I'm not
having a raspy voice I'm having an
easily voice which is actually worse
than my normal voice it's giving Janice
from Friends
I don't know her it's giving annoying
sick [ __ ] yeah no when I like listen to
really old podcast episodes of ours I
really know this is what we sounded like
all the time yes I noticed how much our
voices have changed over the years and
you would think I would have thought
that like my voice a couple of years ago
was like a little bit more New York and
a little more obnoxious valley girl no
we were like nasally as [ __ ] yeah I
wonder if that's youth
what is that I don't know and how can
one change in it like can you change
your voice no you can change the way
that you talk
maybe if I talked in a lower register
pexy if I spoke in a lower register
perhaps I would get more respect
perhaps yeah you know I um there is like
a lot of not a lot there's like a few
women out there who are like really
really deep voices and then you hear
them talk like a lot of people are
always surprised by how Gigi hadid's
voice is because she has like a man
voice yeah this girl I went to Camp with
um Gabby doctor she had a man voice and
she like made it her whole personality
she like loved it she really she
literally was like those
crazy it's so crazy what is that I
wonder if you could get like a voice
transplant
you can't get a voice transplant but I
know if you take hormones like if you're
transitioning your voice changes
maybe I should take hormones maybe but
you but you don't like your voice now no
no I actually my voice now is fine
doesn't bother me except when I'm sick
no sometimes like if like you'll hear
like a recording of yourself or like
there's a video and you're in the
background and then you actually when
you hear that what you have to do is
find the nearest cliff and jump off jump
like there are certain like you when
you're just like living your life like
not caring about anything you'll stumble
upon a recording of yourself that you
hear your voice and it's so shrill and
it's so like goes to the center of your
brain and you're like Jesus [ __ ]
Christ that's what I sound like I
actually can't listen like I I can't
physically can't
well I actually watched our episode from
yesterday uh last night because I just
wanted to
relive the the beautiful moment and
our voices sounded gorgeous but I was
like on one yesterday with the cutting
off it was really [ __ ] annoying I had
to assume maybe it was like the way I
edited it like maybe I didn't line up
art because I was being really [ __ ]
annoying oh interesting I could barely
watch the clips from yesterday because I
look so I look and sound so sick it made
me want to sneeze
totally I'm like constantly on the verge
of a sneeze that's also the worst part
of being sick is like the teasing of the
STEEZ yeah no but just even like looking
at my face especially in those reels
because you crop and we get kind of
close up and I was weirdly zoomed in
yesterday like oh I meant to remind you
did you of course I did I moved my
camera back to like get away you were so
when I got your video yesterday I'm like
Jesus Christ like literally you're so
[ __ ] close to the camera so nice did
you like readjust or something no I
don't I must have just like accidentally
zoomed in at some point yeah yeah
anyways I moved her back but like under
my nose is red and I just it was making
me like feel sicker so I couldn't really
relive the highlights but that's what
you get when you don't have sick days
I wanted to relive the highlights I also
just wanted to there were such heated
debates in our comment section about
Megan and Harry oh I saw some of them
what's so funny is like the
people who are mad at us for
um like for not going hard enough
against and then there's people who are
mad for not being nice enough to like
with these two you actually cannot win
there's no like thing that you could say
that would be one interesting and to
please everyone
um yeah so just say what you think no so
I actually thought like our our comment
section yesterday was really reflective
of of us doing a good job because you're
right people were mad we didn't go hard
enough and then people were mad we went
too hard so it's like which is it girly
um so I felt like that means we gave
like a fair and balanced conversation
about it yeah and yeah
polarizing I fully expect for my
thoughts and feelings to change in a 180
degree Direction when I watch the second
half
um but I mean I'm not going in biased I
just think that you know up until the
wedding like I have no issue with them
why would I have an issue with what
they're showing it's everything that
happens after so I yeah we shall see
also I'm pretty sure I S I know I said
this when we were talking about them
visiting the army base like I know Harry
was in the Army in the UK like of course
like but I I still don't see why like
people in the U.S it just still feels
random military members of the US like
carry to meet and greet the two of them
yeah
um so I rewatched the episode we you
looked stunning don't worry about it and
today you look even more gorgeous
garages
it's 24 degrees in New York wow it's it
is also a little chilly here oh please
no it's like I used to my I keep my
house cold so I used to go outside to
warm up and now
not not happening
by the way I cook the most delicious
meal last night like it was so good I
made like one of the Aina chicken
just you know chicken in the pot sort of
things it was so fantastic I had such a
Hearty dinner I was just feeling so
hashtag proud speaking of that I will be
you know in your home for a variety of
days
um I just want to make sure you're like
stocked up on things because I fully
expect a home-cooked meal every night I
would like einst chicken which one
engagement you want an engagement
chicken
yeah I don't really by the way I don't
love that lemon chicken that you make of
hers because I don't like lemon chicken
okay great that's fine no like I want
like a roast chicken with mashed
potatoes for one meal okay and if to
book your flight so I know if you'll be
here if I should have dinner ready for
you on Thursday yeah yeah yeah I'm like
I'm Ben software's really rubbing off on
me like not booking a flight for
Thursday
and it's Tuesday I actually really need
to do that I just and let me ask so I
loved the mashed potatoes that I made
for Thanksgiving I would make them again
for you do you like a chunky Mansion no
you don't like no I like creamy I like
whipped I like buttery garlic
deliciousness whipped buttery and I'm
I'm guessing no skin
get the [ __ ] skin out of here okay
okay okay
no skin no skin no happening
um
I feel like maybe you know a chili would
be good for the weekend
I don't know what have you made recently
that I thought was like really delicious
looking oh
you had my meatballs
right here for chicken parm no I wasn't
here for chicken parm do you want
chicken parm I would love chicken parm
okay and you know like I'm leaving in
the middle of your stay so I'll leave
some stuff in the freezer like chili is
perfect in the freezer if you just put
it on the pot yeah no and then like I
don't want to make Olivia cook for me
you know she was like a newborn right
I'm so excited you know it'll be a
fabulous weekend and then we'll finally
be together to record well not finally
we were just together we will be
together to record the final episode of
the year I'm going to try not to get
emotional but I don't know if you maybe
missed yesterday's episode Friday is our
last episode of the Year we're back in
the new year two weeks off of the toast
so you better enjoy your girlies while
you still can yeah I feel like starting
with yesterday's episode I'm I'm
beginning to wrap my head around the
fact that a year is coming to an end
yeah which is important to take stock of
your year you know what I think we
average about 200 episodes a year a
little more
um this is actually our year with the
least amount of episodes because we took
a month off for my tour and maternity
leave so I think we'll probably round
out about like 180 which is still so
many still so many it's crazy Plus
patreon
plus plus a baby
plus the most important thing in the
entire world rodini Rodin
rodini rodine
and you know what let's talk about that
because I don't even know if I've
properly told you and like really
thanked you for bringing rold into my
life like I know you did it for you and
like I probably wasn't even a thought
you know like I'm not gonna have this
baby for my [ __ ] sister like I know
like it probably wasn't even a thought
but the way I've never been the same the
way me and this child are so connected
so inextricably linked I can't put into
words the Gratitude I feel I know it
wasn't easy the nine months the labor
and the weaning the breasts the back the
sleepless nights I know and I know you
didn't do it for me nonetheless I'm
grateful
thank you so much and I really do think
that your guys's connection is due in
part to LC hosting the toast with me
side by side for nine months because am
I crazy or like whenever Harry hears my
voice on FaceTime or obviously that in
person he like he knows me like he
always he's like very and I don't see
him have that connection with counts
no not necessarily with the counts on
The Voice level no on a voice level I'd
like to say so the second my face comes
on face time he like looks to the phone
he's like oh that's my [ __ ] well yeah
he also just likes the excitement but I
do think it's your voice
I I definitely think
he heard you know every morning getting
together talking for an hour you know I
talk all over you I yell I scream
there's no way he didn't hear me yeah no
that's what they say they really they
make sense it does make sense and I I
also think that's why when toasters
bring they're like children to meet and
greets and stuff they like newborns the
child is connected to me too like they
feel my energy because a lot of women
listen while pregnant listen in labor
like there's a lot of toasty
reverberations going to the uterine wall
because the toast respects new and
expecting mamas and that's why you
should get your thank you Mama's
Merchant toastmarch.com you should what
a great gift stocking stuffer
stuff it in that stocking let me ask you
a question as a mother [ __ ] up my
mother no drama
when somebody gets you a gift but like
it's for Harry does it count like
a new gift it's just like any other gift
like is it a good one
like if someone gets me like a cute
onesie for him like yeah that that is
for me too so you feel like you got a
present yeah like if you got me a bunch
of stuff for Harry I'd be like oh
Claudia just got me a gift look let's
say we weren't sisters I was coming to
your house for a dinner party and like
you know instead of getting you like a
gorgeous vase I was I got you like this
cute basket full of baby Tings like do
you feel like you got a present yeah
yeah okay I think so and I also feel
that way as a gift Giver like if I'm
shopping for Olivia or something like
maybe it's for Kayla
yeah cause like when I go to it's like
stay at Brian's house I used to bring
like a gift for him but now I just bring
a gift for Dean and it's like is that
the same I think also there are gifts
that are for
parent and baby like you could get a
really nice blanket and it's like okay I
have to be seen with this blanket and
that it's decorative a nice you know
blanket that fits my vibe then it's like
part of my outfit and I think it's then
for both of us
yeah yeah yeah I feel that yeah but you
know if it's a diaper it that is what it
is no no it's not like a functional gift
it's like something like decorative and
we're like fabulous a diaper bag that's
a reflection on me as well
um so I did want to tell everyone you
told me before we have the weirdest
stories but I feel like those make for
the best episodes there's not like any
breaking celeb news it's holiday season
celebs are starting to go on vacation
we're not going to be getting like
that's why there's no toast like
eventually like the celebrities turn off
their publicist for two weeks so
everyone can go home and enjoy yeah like
we had done
maybe like almost 900 episodes of the
toast in total right yeah we're almost
at a thousand and I can say with
certainty that the characters in these
five stories have never been discussed
in an episode together
I'm excited one because I don't know
them but two because the one that I do
know is about the Sister Wives and
that's a subject I'm extremely
passionate about you are it's a Claudia
Explains It All moment and I will and
you know what I was reading the article
because I wanted to be you know brushed
up you will die if you know what I did I
don't watch the new season I just like
watch them in high school and I feel
like a weird connection to them
um one of the Sister Wives is leaving
and the base of their divorce is over
coveted protocols you're gonna die
oh I love that like someone's being a
Karen oh my God but like three years
later no no you'll see you'll see I'll
explain it can't wait yeah so now
without further Ado the stripes Brothers
will be reunited and in studio I don't
care what we have to do to bribe them in
here they will we will have a stride day
Friday all hands on deck for those
people to keep them there all night we
will keep them there till four literally
without further Ado About the dues here
are the past five stories that you do
need to know
and today's episode is brought to you by
away away is a travel company that
believes that the more we travel the
better we become and that's why they
make suitcases bags and other travel
accessories designed to make moving
through the world a lot easier
um I feel like everyone has a way it's
like really become the go-to suitcase
travel accessory company I have like
four now actually left one at your at
your house I need to bring it home I
need it
um don't worry about it it is really the
best suitcase if you're traveling for
the holidays check out a ways range of
suitcases bags other travel Essentials
made for the different types of
travelers all of their suitcases are
built to last they have durable
lightweight exteriors they can withstand
the roughest of baggage handlers and
each suitcase comes with a little it's
like a magic eraser thing it's like a
sponge because if you get your bag back
from baggage claim and it's like hella
scuffed up you use this sponge and you
could buff out the scuffs it's really
smart I only just recently learned that
um also every suitcase comes with an
interior organization system that
includes a built-in compression pad to
help you pack more in and a hidden slash
movable laundry bag for your dirty
undies because we've been talking for
years at the toast about how no company
has really thought about dirty undies
they're not keeping dirty undies in mind
until away they're thinking about your
dirty undies it's a great uh laundry bag
also the bags have four 360 degree
spinner wheels that guarantee the
smoothest rolls even through the most
hectus of airports that have carpets
um which is so unnecessary and so evil
tea uh away has got you covered they
have a TSA approved combination lock and
a sleeve that slides over your suitcase
to keep them safe so there's an 100-day
travel trial on everything that they
make take the product out on the road
you can live with it they offer free
returns and shippings except for the
personalized products so this holiday
season giftaway at awaytravel.com toast
that's awaytravel.com toast today's
episode is also brought to you by ear
doctor clean air is one of the fastest
and easiest ways we can have a positive
impact on our health we can improve the
quality of your indoor air quality with
an air purifier and all you have to do
is breathe so whether it's asthma or
allergies certain steps can be taken to
ensure that your indoor air quality is
healthy that's why you've got to check
out Air Doctor you're breathing 20 000
breaths a day and Air Doctor is
filtering out dangerous contaminants
allergens so your lungs don't have to
air doctor uses an ultra HEPA filter
that's been independently tested to
remove 99.9 percent of bacteria and
viruses Americans are spending ninety
percent of our time indoors and
according to the EPA and indoor air can
be two to five times more polluted than
outdoor air with the winter months we're
all hunkering down make sure that your
indoor air quality is premium with the
air doctor
so we have the air doctor in our studio
and normally we wouldn't be able to have
like an air purifier in the studio
because it makes a lot of sound but this
one is like quiet it's efficient it's
gorgeous too it like Blends in
seamlessly it's not big and ugly
um it takes the guesswork out of clean
air with the auto mood it uses a laser
sensor to detect air quality and
automatically will adjust to the correct
filtration level air doctor comes with a
no questions asked 30-day money-back
guarantee so if you don't love it just
send it back with a refund minus
shipping head to airdoctor Pro and use
promo code toast depending on the model
you receive you'll maybe get up to 35
percent off so it's up to 35 off but
only when you go to airdoctor Pro
air-d-o-c-t-o-r-p-r-o.com use promo code
toast airdoctorpro.com promo code toast
for up to 35 off
love the air doctor you keep one in
Harry's room and it's just wonderful
making sure his hair is clean enough
amen first story Kendall and Kylie
Jenner poke fun at the Lisa Rena Kathy
Hilton feud in his husband so Kendall
and Kylie are going viral in the Real
Housewives Community because they
jokingly joined in on the tequila gate
drama between their family friends Kathy
Hilton and Lisa Rinna that infamously
led to a falling out on the Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills they filmed
a tick tock video at Kimo Sabe in Aspen
Colorado the same cowboy hat store where
Rina upset Kathy Hilton by ordering
Kendall's 818 tequila rather than Kathy
Hilton's Casa del Sol which Hilton had
attempted to promote throughout a cash
trip the audio says I just want to try
it because it's my friend Kendall
Jenner's tequila so I haven't tried it
they recreated the scene in their video
as a bartender report each of them a
glass of 818 and then the bottles on the
Shelf now have like tags that say
Kendall's tequila and Kathy's tequila
yeah it was really funny albeit you know
a little delayed but I mean they just
went out they're not gonna go to Aspen
to film it but the fact that they're in
that same house they could have used the
sound like before like Kendall could
have like made a cocktail with it but I
do appreciate the authenticity of them
actually being an aspen at Kimo sabe I
recognized it immediately and when I saw
that it was from Kendall Jenner's
account I'm like what is going on it was
like dystopic I loved it but I also kind
of hated that like they're acknowledging
Lisa Rena because that's like exactly
what she wanted and like sorry Lisa that
article said Lisa and Kathy are both
family friends
Kathy you're my family friend yeah
Lisa's just like like a thirst monster
in Hollywood who maybe they run into
sometimes yeah but it's crazy that
Kendall tequila was such a big storyline
in Real Housewives she had yet to
address it and now I'm just glad that
she knows about it and maybe they won't
Kendall Jenner maybe they watch the show
maybe they don't uh
but this was like you know the the um
Sweet Life of Hannah Montana on Deck
like it was the crossover we all needed
that is literally the perfect comparison
it was cute Kylie um
seems to be having a really fun time in
Aspen this is like the time of year when
like all the celebs go to Aspen and it's
like hot spot and I feel like we'll be
getting some good content yeah I feel
like Kylie is never where everyone else
is oh great and I actually feel like her
being in Aspen right now is still like
not it's not Christmas New Year's like
it's before and I love that for her all
the girls have been quiet I feel like
they're going through a rough patch
because
of Balenciaga gate and it's like
affecting everything it's just it's been
like a series of unfortunate events for
them what else after no it's just been
like you know Kanye doesn't reflect
great on them okay but I don't believe
in blaming I do not believe in blaming
other people for other people's actions
but it's like his it's his family and
they really never have said anything
about it and like it's a little you know
um then the Balenciaga thing and then I
just feel like it's like this General at
least for me like it's this General
fatigue I feel like they're sensing that
and they're just like being quiet for a
while because you know up until like
maybe a month or two ago it was a
stellar year for the girlies yeah I
think they're laying low for me it's
only the Balenciaga thing and that
doesn't affect the way that I see uh
what's her name Kylie
um Kylie Kendall
Chloe like it's really just Kim for me
and I just feel like Kim keeps posting
like all this mindless [ __ ] thinking
that like that's usually a good PR
strategy like it's what Ariel Target
said like it is good like just keep the
conversation going but like everything
she posts I'm just like
what about Balenciaga yeah no totally
um I think a lot of people also like for
us like we're like staunch Defenders
so I feel like I wasn't getting bothered
by [ __ ] that they were doing
but I know a lot of people were very put
off by the Astro World
oh yeah and rightfully so I mean like
I'm a Kylie Defender but like even I was
like you know yeah yeah no but so I'm
saying if we're like if we're feeling
this way right I imagine it I think I
think they're taking note like I I
really do feel like they're much more
pulled back I think it's also the
holiday time like they're like done
working for the year they're on
vacations Kim was just in the posting
somewhere in the ocean so they've been
quiet and I do I think that's for the
best sometimes you know you just need a
break yeah but if you're gonna come out
make it with a viral Tick Tock that we
can't deny we can't ignore yeah
so that's what the girlies are up to my
friend Kendall Jenner
are you ready for our next story
captain Lee has been forced to exit
below deck he said this has been one of
the most humbling experiences of his
life captain Lee rossback is
disembarking from below deck the Bravo
personality announced his exit on
Monday's episode informing his crew that
persistent health issues meant he'd need
to bow out of season 10 early he was
admittedly struggling with nerve issues
when he boarded the motor yacht Saint
David at the start of the charter season
but he hoped his symptoms would subside
over time instead he shared in a
confessional interview quote my injury
it's getting worse the left side of my
body I don't feel anything I expected a
lot more progress than I'm experiencing
and the most frustrating part about it
is I can't do a goddamn thing about it
and it's hard later he told the chef
that this has probably been one of the
most humbling experiences of my life as
the episode went on he realized he had
to consider that his health concerns
might have an impact on the whole boat
the Pain's getting worse not better I
owe it to my crew to do right by by them
they expect that out of me there comes a
point if a captain is really being
objective he should be putting the best
interest of his crew first because
that's your primary responsibility as
soon as you step on board check your
[ __ ] ego at the dock that's where you
leave it
then he called an all-hand teacher and
made the decision to leave the boat
and obviously it's so much more than
leaving the boat he's leaving the show
right and he's really um the backbone of
this show I think like so much of the
success of
below deck has to do with like people
loving captain Lee and like his no
[ __ ] energy and I remember I I
watched below Tech in the very beginning
and they had another girly come after
Captain land she never made it and then
they ended up with Captain Sandy who's
great but like Captain Lee was really
like the OG Captain this is very sad I
do think the show will suffer Captain
Sandy's great but she only does half of
the shows you know yeah um they have to
bring in someone to replace captain Lee
for the other half of the shows I think
they have very big shoes to fill
hopefully captain Lee can recommend a
fellow Captain who he respects and who
he also thinks you know America would
respect but because
captain Lee is like also a really
popular Bravo Liberty like they loved
him at bravocon I and I'm sure he'll
actually stay involved in stuff like
that but
you know the body
is an important thing to have you know
I don't like the way I started that
sentence sorry you know you need to be
healthy for a job as physical as being a
boat captain you know you're outside all
day roping and swinging and lassoing so
what you're saying is you need to listen
to your body
and it appears as though captain Lee is
listening to the influencers and he's
listening to his body and for that we
have to respect him and just be happy
yeah I I feel like Captain Lee 10 years
ago if you had told him like you are
going to be a Bravo Liberty he would
have like laughed in your face it's so
improbable how like this man he's so
serious he takes his job so seriously
which is why we love him but the yacht
veteran no and he's not he's not like
thirsty no so the course that his career
took I'm sure was just as unexpected for
him as it seems to us it's a fascinating
transition it is but I'm ready I want
like a captain Lee
they don't need to break the mold with
the next guy like Captain lay clone
carbon copy like a really
um serious someone who you know with
this with a soft heart
yeah but someone who takes yachting very
seriously I sometimes feel like Captain
Sandy's a little too soft yeah she's
always partying with the guests no she's
not but like people are always getting
in trouble and like it's fine you know
captain Lee it's like you you get maybe
one strike he runs a tight [ __ ] ship
and also and that's why people respect
him this is a reality show it's all fun
and games but you are on this Behemoth
on the water and someone needs to keep
you safe so it has to be the reality
show Captain right and I do feel like
Captain Lee makes sure that of course
like the [ __ ] the people are working and
they're making content for the TV show
but like really the safety of the guests
on board is his number one priority yeah
I believe that yeah so I think that it's
gonna be hard to find you know a
non-thirsty captain at this point but I
think that they could there are so few
I would hope that there aren't you know
yeah considering how many lives are at
stake yeah
so did you ever do below deck like as a
guest if I could ask if I could take out
the element of me being a bathing suit
like just set that up no no oh no it's a
real element not unless I lose 100
pounds no no like for me
one what I found really interesting is
we had been asked once like I have an
email about it somewhere you have to pay
for the charge yeah we were like asked
to apply yeah you have to you have to
pay for the charter
um and I think for like a
four day Friday Charter it was like 60
Grand which is still a [ __ ] ton of money
but it's a major discount for a boat
like that in that part of detailed so
you get a discount because you're going
to be [ __ ] tortured
um
so one I don't know if I would want to
pay that amount of money to like not
enjoy a vacation
two
I definitely don't want to be on TV in a
bathing suit like kill me three
sometimes not all the time the guests
become a part of the storyline they
become villainized
um for being difficult and we are not
difficult to actually think we would
come off great like we would be fun and
we also like we wouldn't make them like
blow up the water like we just want to
lay out and like drink eat and go to
sleep yeah but then they make it like
these guests are so boring and they're
like yeah yeah no I do think they would
villainize us so that's another reason I
wouldn't want to do it I actually if I
could be comfortable like with how I
looked you know if I just happen to be
feeling myself and I could you know not
beware and also I'm not gonna be in a
bathing suit like I'll be wearing a
cover-up okay of course and then you
know maybe we have like a mysterious
benefactor who's willing to come with us
and like pay for a lot of it and we just
have to like pay what a normal vacation
would cost Brian dvg right right by the
way he has been asked as well of course
his episode would actually be great he's
like a travel expert those two big
things like I don't have to like worry
about them in a major way I actually
think it would be great one it would be
great for the toast of course like it
would be so exciting for the toasters
who love below deck and like podcast on
the boat and make them like film us
right like well not even for that but
like for the like even if they never
mentioned who we are and what we do like
the toasters who watch the show
religiously like would love to see us on
it and I don't worry about coming off
poorly like because I think we're
Pleasant like I will the only uh
specificity that I have is like meat you
know and that's the only thing that work
uh particular about I've thought about
that too because like before every guest
comes on they sit with like a full sheet
of paper on like their dietary
restrictions and we would probably have
to like ship meat from America or from
like the near nearest kosher butcher
um and they'd be like what is this right
right so they would probably make that a
thing but like okay make yourself look
anti-semitic go ahead yeah no you do
yeah below Jack you do yeah but
otherwise like and then if they were if
they did like drum up drama and make us
look terrible but like I had no personal
issue with how I behaved and I like
didn't act a fool like that's fine make
yourself a lot a lot of the drama is
like them complaining about food and as
previously discussed like I would rather
jump off the boat than ever send
anything back or complain about my food
like I'll just swallow it or like feed
it to Theo so I think we're good yeah no
I think we would have one would be an
amazing vacation I think we would have a
good time I think it would be good for
the business like also Jackie you're
forgetting you get seasick you can't go
on a boat no but I've been on boats
before and I just I have a
a system like I do the sea bands I do
Dramamine and then like if towards if it
gets worse there are patches that you
can like put on your neck that like are
magic and zofran and Zofran so I I could
do it and for the work
I'm a workaholic totally
so I'm I'm open to it but the first
piece has to just be the the somebody
has to pay for it
yeah right so we'll see yeah but you
never know never say like I don't think
it's the worst idea
it actually it actually makes sense and
it reminds me of Say Yes to the Dress
like even though you have such negative
things to say about it and you're you
hate so many things about it I think
ultimately like it's amazing that you
did it it's like this of course funnest
facts weirdly discovered you from Say
Yes to the Dress right like if I could
go back in time I wouldn't take it back
right
but I would change a few things like
getting my mole removed right would you
change anything about the way that you
acted like no they made a storyline they
acted cute we were fun we were not being
difficult I just said like as any normal
human being would like what kind of
dress are you looking for I'm looking
for long sleeves oh she's looking for
long slaves like yeah they have to do
that let them do it right yeah don't let
me started on the girl from Louisiana
like please right right no but like see
they manufacture stuff so you as long as
like you feel good that you were like a
you're a good person and that you
treated everyone with respect like let
them do their TV magic yeah no that's
fair
are you ready for our next story yeah a
little posthumous drama because Leonard
Cohen's kids are in a battle over the
singer's 48 million dollar estate now
Claudia for anyone who doesn't know who
Leonard Cohen is could you break
it to your kitchen chair she broke your
throne she cut your hair and from your
lips she drew the Hallelujah
Hallelujah oh yeah
hallelujah hallelujah
[Music]
Hallelujah
I really should go about the mask singer
you really should and you guys might
know that song from Shrek it's just a
beautiful shed dead I also um by the way
there are actually a lot of songs like I
exclusively know from Shrek I need a
hero I'm looking out for a hero till the
end of the night he's gotta be strong
and he's gotta be smart and he's gotta
be some night also Hey Now You're an
All-Star get your game on go play
so good
oh good anyways Leonard Cohen there is a
lot of drama surrounding his estate so
he passed away uh like for in 2016 and
in the years before his passing he
worked to secure most of his
multi-million dollar estate for the
benefit of his heirs he has two children
named Lorca and Adam it's a battle that
includes accusations of forgeries
Secrets and allegations that the singer
didn't trust his own offspring to run
his estate because before he passed he
did have a trustee
um in charge of his estate the trustee
is named Robert Corey the trust controls
tens of millions of dollars in royalties
for his music as well as poetry novels
photographs and 243 journal notebooks
that he had when he died that he had
started since he was a teenager and he
passed away at 82. the so-called called
Lenin Cohen Leonard Cohen archives
it's a lot of words Leonard Cohn archive
is valued at more than 48 million
dollars court filings say Leonard Cohn
passed away unexpectedly at the after
fall in his home in the middle of the
night so if he had any loose ends to tie
up with his estate he did not have a
chance to do them the children say that
their father came to appreciate in his
waning days that he had made a grave
error by allowing this guy to insinuate
himself into Leonard's Affairs and take
control over virtually every aspect of
Leonard's finances and Legacy court
papers say
the kids claim that they have not been
kept appraised by this trustee Quarry of
recent efforts to monetize his estate
including the posthumous publication of
a Cohen novel called a ballet of lepers
published earlier this year and the
opening of everybody knows which is an
exhibit at Toronto's Art Gallery of
Ontario which opens to the public on
Tuesday
so they are so so who do we believe by
the way like do we believe the kids
I'm inclined to believe the kids
plus there are allegations that um one
of the documents is forged that would
that put uh this guy on the trust
instead of the kids so that needs to be
looked at I would need to like go over
Leonard's relationship with his kids
over the years you know but I feel like
it's giving Colonel Tom
Parker Parker from Elvis like there are
managers and just like Biz people who
take advantage of their clients
especially elderly clients so true and
exploit the estate but I do want to say
this
case of exploiting the estate is a book
and an Art Exhibit like sounds okay I
don't know Toronto Film Festival an
exhibit called everybody knows everybody
knows sounds pretty respectful honestly
sounds very classy right it's not like
they're you know starting like he's not
in sing three
stage or like there's a hologram tour a
holographic tour around the country of
Leonard Cohn doing slam poetry as a
hologram
sin
Jesus died for our sin yes no like there
are so many more tacky ways this guy so
at least he's in some small way
respecting the Legacy and not just
totally destroying it yeah also fun fact
is that in the copious notes that are
part of his archive they have the
original version of Hallelujah which is
82 verses it's giving all too well ten
minute version I [ __ ] love that song
it's not a cry that you hear at night
it's not someone who's seen the light
it's a cold remember when Carly Rose son
and Claire's saying that song on X
Factor and like literally nobody was
okay no we were not okay
and she had a gospel choir and she wore
a big white dress and it was like really
moving no I need to go watch that after
the episode and she did like these
harmonies that's what I was just trying
to do but I [ __ ] it up it was like
really beautiful that's that's gorgeous
honestly every time I sing it it's like
one of my go-to songs of my repertoire
the lyrics are not [ __ ] English okay
I've seen your flag on the Marble Arch
and love is not a victory march it's a
cold and it's a Broken Hallelujah like
the [ __ ] does that mean okay let me look
up the lyrics
because maybe it's part of a larger
story you have to go in order
baby I've been here before I know this
room I've walked this floor I used to
live alone before I knew you oof that is
that makes me feel like yeah I've seen
your flag on the Marble Arch but listen
love love is not some kind of victory
march no it's cold and it's ever a
Broken Hallelujah
I'm not understanding
I've seen it but on the Marble Arch
maybe it's like you see the flag on the
arch which it would signify like the end
of victory march but there's no end with
love like it's an ongoing thing it's a
broken heart like you know what I mean
like it's not just like if there's a
Finish Line and with love you know what
I actually need like an a 10th grade
English class member we used to just sit
and like decipher this dumb old [ __ ]
yeah and like nobody cared because we
were too young to appreciate it that's
what I need with the song
yeah
beautiful stuff check it out for
yourselves let us know what you think
Halloween means in the comments I hope
those Cohen kids you know figure that
out I do hope Justice is served because
I when this sort of stuff happens it's
horrible like someone's Legacy
especially posthumously like he's not
here to speak for himself and to take
advantage and also it's like his work
isn't garbage like it's so meaningful
it's like religious almost yeah no I
agree it's different than like someone
who you know singing someone else's
words like this is his heart and soul
and so it seems like a true artist yeah
for it to be mishandled in any way is
really appalling no in the Colonel Tom
Parker comparison is a great one yeah
like Elvis didn't write all of his own
songs you know he's saying a lot of
other people's songs nothing makes it
any different whatever yeah but it's
like this is like it's also different
when it's like someone's poetry like
does it get more personal no no more
personal than comedy and poetry is more
personal than food
100 I would actually say like right now
in thinking about it poetry I think is
the most personal thing I've ever
thought of no it's a deeply like
personal we should keep a list of the
most persons in order okay because we
have poetry obviously food comedy and
travel
um I would go
poetry
comedy
food
travel
poetry comedy food travel and then don't
forget about
reading books
I would put that above travel
I think travel is so personal like some
person might want to go hike Machu
Picchu and another person might want to
land the beach and for those two people
like the other sounds everything on this
list is personal but something has to be
left
so true and you know what they're so
personal that I think even the ranking
list is different I agree personal
ranking lists are more personal than
comedy travel poetry
and food and you know what else is so
personal podcasts
you want to spend your time with I want
to spend my time with Jackson Claude
those gorgeous girlies
agreed and you know what that's just a
universal truth ain't that the truth
well speaking of uh Universal truths
today's episode is sponsored by Legacy
box the countdown to Christmas Hanukkah
Kwanzaa is on order today to get your
legacy box in time for the holidays
Legacy box is a great gift for you or
someone you love you can join the
millions of customers who've trusted
Legacy box to safeguard their recorded
moments protect your treasure tapes your
film reels and your photos from floods
from mold even just from the decay of
time Legacy box is a simple and safe way
to digitize your treasured videotapes
your film reels and photos they've
helped over a million families even
hours do just that not to mention
everything they do is done by hand right
in the U.S you can convert your media to
digital copies that will always be
protected from floods from mold or even
from the decay of time wrap up your
holiday shopping where prices are
starting at under forty dollars Legacy
boxes in stock and ready to ship make
this holiday season special and give the
gift of memories so you know we grew up
in a VHS house and I feel like for many
years we tried different ways of like
watching ah just is on our DVD players
and then on our Apple TVs it was really
hard Legacy box was the most seamless
process I can't recommend it enough it
is an amazing gift for a really
sentimental person in your life like a
family member
um whatever types of like tapes you have
most likely Legacy box can handle it
basically when you buy it they will ship
you a box they will ship you a package a
slip so you just package it all up send
it out and if you use our code you'll
get a great deal with Christmas just
around the corner there's still time to
take advantage of the best Christmas
gift ever Legacy box please visit
legacybox.com toast to take advantage of
our an exclusive discount for our
listeners the boxes are still in stock
and they're ready to ship so all you
have to do is visit
legacybox.com toast for an exclusive
offer that's legacybox.com toast today's
episode is also brought to you by go
macro or as I like to call it Goma crow
in the face of adversity and a fight for
survival against cancer a mother and
daughter took their love to the kitchen
and go macro was born now they are
spreading the power of balanced
plant-based lifestyle across the country
country with go macro
they are available in 16 mouthwatering
full size and five kids flavors macro
bars are packed with 100 plus
plant-based ingredients to fuel your
body and mind pack your bags with your
new favorite snack with the holiday
travel season ramping up macro bars are
the perfect on-the-go snack each bar is
loaded with delicious organic
ingredients and plant-based goodness to
keep you fueled throughout the day not
only do they make delicious bars but
they also make a positive change towards
a better Planet go macro has partnered
with terracycle to create a national
recycling program for the go macro
wrappers once they're collected
terracycle
processes the wrappers back into raw
material that can be used to make items
like park benches playgrounds and deck
material joint go macro as they help
make a better future for our planet by
going to terracycle.com and signing up
for a free account and you can get your
hands on a delicious plant-based protein
bar by going to go macro.com use promo
code toast for 30 off plus free shipping
on all orders over fifty dollars Jackie
I feel like you're a bar expert these
days and you love go macro even they've
been in our studio before they were a
sponsor I'm always a bar expert
mcclartia and I love the go macro bars
they're so tasty and they will actually
keep you full it's not just like
something that you tied over until like
you find a snack five minutes later like
it's I personally use them as a meal
replacement especially breakfast if I
don't have time to like sit down and
make a meal or I want to like you know
have it up here with me while I pick the
stories go macro is like my breakfast of
choice when I don't have the time or the
energy to make a real breakfast and I
know that it's going to keep me full
till lunch like that's my favorite thing
about it it's made with amazing stuff
and they taste so good there are so many
different flavors too so it's like go
macro flavors are more personal than
comedy more personal for than food but
there's something for everyone like
really some of the flavors are not my
favorites but then there are some that
are like my favorite I really hope that
the sister wife story is next is it it
is
thank God Sister Wives Janelle and Cody
Brown split after almost 30 years of
marriage sister wife Stars Janelle and
Cody Brown shocked viewers on following
Sunday's season finale of the TLC
reality Series in a trailer for the
upcoming one-on-one specials the former
spouses confirm that they are currently
separated after nearly 30 years of
marriage they tied the knot in 1993 and
share six adult children together the
split comes after a very tense year for
the Brown family in the wake of
Christine Brown's divorce from Cody and
her decision to move away from Flagstaff
Arizona to Utah the split put a strain
on Janelle's marriage to Cody as she
continued to spend time with Christine
and her kids but there were many other
factors that affected the pair's
marriage especially in more recent years
so one of the big things that affected
our marriage was covid protocols in
February 2021 Cody told Entertainment
Tonight quote Janelle and I I think are
in a good place covenants put a real
strain on her time together but we've
survived times like this in the past
there's no trouble in Paradise Janelle
agreed at the time saying Cody and I
have definitely had challenges this year
because we've had to spend more time
apart than we ever have probably so it's
definitely something I've had to think
about and realize I still like him and
want him around so that was kind of nice
we've been married almost 30 years more
time apart than ever
who in covid but anyways no because they
all live in separate houses got it but
that's changed as the wives started
pointing out that some of Cody's
hypocrisy when it comes to his coveted
protocols this past season of Sister
Wives he officially he officiated an
indoor wedding without quarantining
afterward despite forcing his wives to
quarantine from from him if they
traveled anywhere in Sunday so he
essentially like for his family he's
like the patriarch he makes all the
rules he had these really strict coveted
restrictions in place for his family
that everyone had to follow except for
him right right so he would officiate a
wedding and then now quarantine uh Cody
told Janelle he didn't feel supported by
her when it came to his coveted
restrictions which she took offense to
she said Cody's acting like I was a kova
denier I was not a coven denier I
followed all the CDC rules I wore a mask
I washed my hands I was careful I'm
vaccinated for crying out loud I don't
have to stand here and defend myself I
don't have to be beaten into submission
no that's not [ __ ] Cody like trying
to Gaslight his wife into like being a
coveted denier like you're literally not
even following your own [ __ ]
rules [ __ ] yeah no rules but they're so
that's so Cody Jackie like you don't
understand like rules for everyone
except for him like that is so Cody to a
t rules for thee but not for me
it's so hypocritical and I like love
that they're calling him out and
obviously that's not why you break up a
marriage but I think like no but I think
it reveals something about a person's
personality one to have like such
Draconian restrictions like in your own
house when we're almost three years up
and like that's [ __ ] psychotic and
two to not even apply them to yourself
no like that's so talk you should walk
the walk and I think this is just a
glimpse into probably some other insane
sort of ways he wants to live his life I
mean aside from being a polygamist
polygamist right but
um
I also think Christine leaving who was
the first wife who left was like a major
move I think like she really gave
Janelle the courage and you know what I
think I said this the last time
if I
wait did Mary also leave
you would know no
but if I would have if I would have
guessed any one of them to leave when I
used to watch a show it would have been
Janelle that's what you said last time
right so I feel like she's probably been
having like a like not a great time for
a while but then they got this TV show
and life was good and they were making a
lot of money from it and they're famous
so
I think that definitely prolonged the
marriage but then seeing Christine who I
never would have guessed Christine I
thought Christine was his favorite so
seeing Christine go probably gave her
the courage and I won't be surprised if
Mary goes next I don't know why I feel
like Mary and him got divorced
I'm not sure but also in a recent
episode one of the sons tierfully
recounted Cody calling him on his
birthday and proceeding only to discuss
kovid and forgetting his son's birthday
in October 21. the sunset that they
haven't spoken since
he's literally obsessed with covet what
the [ __ ] is that and like kovid has
turned into a mental illness for a lot
of people like not being able to let go
of it move past it and I don't know how
you can stay married to someone like
that who can't even remember his son's
birthday because he's so caught up with
covid
okay so now Sister Wives is just Mary
who's the OG wife Robin the last most
recent wife and Cody Brown and fans are
according to this TV show.com fans are
rejecting Sister Wives just starring
Mary Robin and Cody I mean it's just
it's a throuple it's not Sister Wives
okay but it's more than one
yeah but you know I think that Robin was
really the
she shook up the whole family I don't
know if all these divorces would have
happened if they didn't like years later
marry Robin I think she was this young
hot thing they had kids together I think
it was I think it was toxic also I saw
in the article that like he didn't want
to be losing Robin's house so he was
like one of one of the other women to
buy the house I felt like she was being
used just to like secure the house like
I just don't feel like they feel cared
about which is like shocking no he like
literally like it was really with Robin
it was like shiny new thing
mm-hmm
and they had kids together and there was
like very much newlyweds and the other
women they were married for 20 years at
that time like it was it was a slap in
the face yeah
so but you know what happy for Janelle
honestly Christine was always my
favorite so like she's out and I'm glad
Mary is
Mary was the first and honestly she was
the most forgotten about and she like
was so desperate for his attention and
love it was actually sad and the fact
that she's still there is
Reigns true
yeah
so excited like Financial stuff
something with an RV and a coyote
changing Dynamics with you know the way
that the marriage was changing just like
most divorces you know it's not just one
thing one thing no and then they were
like always on the run because they're
literally like living in sin
yeah I also think in reading this like
kovid gave him an excuse to spend more
time with one person than another yes uh
and that's probably why he kept these
protocols in place otherwise they would
be like well you can go from house to
house we're not seeing other people it's
my night tonight Cody but that doesn't
work if no you're so true he doesn't
take it out seriously
it's not even about quotations using
like like fake quarantine to manipulate
to keep them apart
yeah and me like I could spend more time
with Robin I have to quarantine here
sorry yeah and then Robin left him
because she had too much [ __ ] time
with him she's like get the [ __ ] out of
my face Robin didn't leave
Robin didn't leave Robin is the one I
think he likes the best and honestly
Mary is on her way yeah Robin's the one
he was spending the most time with oh so
she's still around okay cool
yeah he loves Robert it's the one yeah
Robin's the most recent addition so now
his remaining wives are Mary and Robin
Mary was the first wife ever and Robin
was the last
and Mary's probably like you know some
girls are like let him get it like out
of his system it's like yeah 30 years of
polygamy I'll get it out of his system
only one two down one to go I think Mary
is honestly just happy to still be here
honestly
like Mary isn't always was like
Desperately Seeking attention from Cody
sad yeah
the story
yes ma'am dictionary.com has chosen
their 2022 word of the year
I hope it's better what was uh Miriam
Webster's
we just reported on it we just did hold
on what was it so true we need to find
it webs
ite wait Jackie stop talking I came here
Gaslight Gaslight okay so I'm so curious
which which
Trend you would prefer here because it's
a trendy word no actually it's the least
trendy word ever it is woman
what dictionary.com has selected the
word woman as its word of the year for
2022 people can exclusively reveal the
word was selected not not dictionary.com
getting political well it's selected for
a number of reasons one um because it's
typical that the word that of the Year
something that has been searched more
than normal and the volume of people
searching the definition of the word
woman has increased exponentially I
think doubled over the last 12 months so
the senior director of
editorialaddictionary.com said woman and
its definition were both at the center
of various consequential moments
discussions and decisions in our society
in 2022 leading them to the selection
selecting woman as our word of the year
he says provides an acknowledgment of
the gravity of the various events
affecting women in 2022
from our perspective as observers and
Recorders of language change the word
woman is a prime example of the many
gender terms undergoing shifts in how
and to whom they're applied
okay so I think it was it's a number of
things one more people searched it than
ever because I think also this like
question of like what is a woman has
been writing all year so I think that
yeah a lot of people to just ask
dictionary.com right but I think they're
also by the way what is the definition
of woman you know what I actually did
the same thing when I was
looking I was like what is the
dictionary definition it is adult female
person a female employee
non-representative that's like using the
the word in a definition yes no a woman
is a is a woman and then so then I was
like okay so what's a female
right what's a female a female is
relating to or being a woman or a girl
oh my God not them sending us in circles
here of relating to or being a person
with a certain combination of sex
characteristics commonly including two X
chromosomes in the cell nuclei a vagina
a uterus and ovaries and enlarged
breasts developed at people oh well then
I'm a woman today
I Am Woman hear me roar in numbers too
big to ignore
um okay well that's definitely different
than Gaslight even though you know
women's favorite activity is gaslighting
that's definitely one of my favorite
activities are similar inextricably
linked
that's so funny
um and then also you know they're taking
their stance in support of women
you know I appreciate that I am a woman
and I've actually felt like in recent
years at dictionary.com didn't have my
back and now that I kind of have
concrete proof that dictionary.com does
in fact have my back I am
Changes Everything Changes Everything
that thing will ever be the same no it
won't do you want to hear what the
runner-ups were sure
um the Ukraine flag emoji
it's not a word that would have been
so terrible if they chose that that's
not a word you cannot choose an emoji
and you think that we think the end of
language you would think that
dictionary.com would know that an emoji
is not a word and that they would be
scrupled and I would also think that
dictionary.com would be like a little
anti-emoji because I do think people use
emojis as like sort of a crutch language
yeah so that was disappointing obviously
I'm glad they didn't choose it but the
fact that it could have been an emoji
that that's literally so stupid I
actually have a question for you but I'm
going to give you the rest of the short
list the word inflation
that is what the year was about yeah
facts quiet quitting
oh that's a good thing it's a trend I'm
actually not familiar with it also um I
don't know how to tell them this that's
two words
oh shots [ __ ] I know but the thing is
they're language experts they're not
math experts
um
can't expect them that's for math.com
you can't expect them to know both yes
not fair another option was democracy
great always important always and Wordle
which was added to the dictionary in
2022 another one that would have been an
insane disappointment especially since
Wordle was relevant for one whole for
one day it was a good month it was the
last month of my maternity leave and
then I gave birth and I never played
again I actually sometimes remember
Wordle as a thing and I just like do it
but I like I wish I kept up with it it's
actually like a fun thing there's been
too many ever since the New York Times
bought it there's been too many like uh
clerical errors where two words work or
you can't get the word yeah and it
wasn't like that before before he said
also when the New York Times bought it
it ruined all the fun like at first it
was just you know people coming together
and now there's corporate greed and it
wasn't it wasn't the vibe and I'm sorry
like Wordle isn't a big enough of a
thing for it to become a word like
Google has now after 30 years of
dominance in the space and it is a verb
it is a word and it's a noun and
honestly the fact that New York Times
bought it and didn't like immediately
release an app
then we would all remember if we got a
notification every day like kind of like
be real like it was it wasn't even
world.com you would have to Google
Wordle and like it was just too hard
yeah so I don't even think it deserves
to be in the dictionary as a word it was
a clear moment and there's just it was a
trend trying they're always everyone's
so thirsty like can't anyone just like
do their jobs and and take the internet
out of it yeah no they can't but I I
wish they would I especially [ __ ]
dictionary.com you would think no but
dictionary.com is like kind of like
cheesy and tacky and like poor poor
man's version of Merriam-Webster yeah
and like dictionary.com doesn't have
like a physical
dictionary right yeah I would actually I
would expect this type of like moronic
sophomoric behavior from dictionary.com
but I expected better from Miriam
yeah they're like Oxford right Oxford
would never never
okay my question for you is what would
you say is your emoji of the year
[ __ ] cares I do what would was your
most used Emoji this year or emoji that
sums up
your feelings
honestly it would just be like the money
flying away
because I feel like I was like grinding
so hard this year but it's like I can't
keep up you know I can't keep up yeah
my favorite emoji I think this is two
years running is the one that's like
that that face that connotes yikes it's
like yeah like squiggly mouth squiggly
mouth and like one eye red yeah
that's mine
um okay so those were the fast moronic
stories that you needed to know and I
feel as though you needed to know them
and I had a great time doing it I really
did
always a pleasure
it's been a pleasure doing business with
you it's been a pleasure sitting down
with y'all thank you so much for
listening to the toast the millennial
Morning Show where we deliver the past
five stories that you need to know every
Monday through Friday on YouTube so if
you're watching us on YouTube please
don't forget to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
this podcast anywhere podcast can be
found on Spotify Institute Republican
radio
about a beautiful stunning and wickedly
talented we are have an amazing day
we'll see you tomorrow for hump day oh
yeah who knows what'll happen on hump
day the last one of the year
anything's possible
bye